what's up guys it was just announced the
all-new secret lab magnus pro
desk
the first standing desk from secret lab
so many of you have been asking for this
they have finally released it i've been
testing this desk for the past couple
weeks this is the 1.7 meter version
there's also a 1.5 meter version and i'm
gonna tell you this is probably one of
my favorite standing desks in the
marketplace
except for this one thing and this one
thing what is it we'll talk about that
in just a bit but first we're going to
focus on the positives what i enjoy
about using this desk and what i like
about it so much
secret lab is still carry that dna over
from trying to keep your cables away
from your desk making sure that when you
look at your desk you don't see cables
all over the place it's clean
it's awesome to look at and that dna is
still here in this magnus pro okay and
the design element is pretty much the
same to be honest with you i mean when
you look at both of these desks beside
the size of it and looking at the legs
you probably wouldn't be able to tell
which desk is which
but
for a lot of you who are worried about
the wobble of the original magnus is
that here in the pro it's not the
standing legs are very secure could hold
up to about 125 kgs of weight on the
desk so that's pretty much good unless
people want to lay on top of it with a
partner and do some other things which
we're not going to talk about in this
video but outside of that you're going
to be more than happy with this um what
else do i like about this desk is the
design it's a little bit less gamer-ish
in my personal opinion what do i mean by
that well when i first got the magnus
desk it had this black matte sort of
magnetic you know covering to it it had
gold writing and had red stitching they
very much kind of it was kind of in your
face right well this one is a stealth
black look it's sleek it's nondescript
if you're a business person or if your
person doesn't want that sort of
bold look to your desk you're going to
really enjoy this now you still have the
rgb lighting on the back of this you are
going to see the red accents here and
there especially in the monitor which
we'll talk about in just a bit and of
course the cable management
magnetic holders for that matter but
outside of that
it is really just sleek black
utilitarian and it feels like it's a
little bit more mature in my personal
opinion okay
but let's also go to some of the
accessories on this first we've got to
talk about the elephant in the room the
monitor arm so many of you were asking
us in our videos what monitor did you
use on the magnus desk how did you get
it so sleek which is that i need to buy
it well that is a prism rx stealth
monitor arm and it fit beautifully on
the magnus and now secret lab has made
their own monitor arm very reminiscent
of that design but it's a little bit
more angular it's matte black with this
metallic red accents that we've seen
from secret lab but this monitor arm has
a p-load of around 8 kgs in weight so i
have this iso 27-inch monitor that i've
been uh borrowing from a friend of mine
ivan joshua lowe who's very kind enough
to loan me this monitor because it'll
monitors are not cheap at all
and
alone without any accessories this
monitor weighs in at 7.7 kg
now with this uh sort of covering the
side covering to reduce glare that's
going to put it around 8 kg thereabouts
this monitor arm holds it no problems at
all it is great you can turn it
vertically horizontally doesn't matter
it's fantastic of course i talked about
this matte here that's all still black
now there are different color
configurations which you've probably
already seen
and yeah some are a little bit more bold
than others but i like this one but i
think a lot of you are going to like
some of the newer accessories this pc
mount bracket that goes to the bottom
right hand side of the desk here now i
don't have that here because my desk is
powered by a macbook pro 16-inch m1 max
which is here on my desk but if you do
have a pc tower you can rig that
underneath the desk it's padded so it's
going to protect your pc tower you can
run your cables to the back of the cable
tray and you're good to go
also you have the magnetic headphone
holder which is great to have especially
for gaming and editing and all that
great stuff and i use that a lot
a lot of the accessories are
interchangeable for the most part i
don't know about the pc mount i know the
monitor arm is and of course the
headphone holder but if you have the
original magnus with those accessories
you can bring that over here to the pro
no issues at all how i have my desk set
up i mean because i need a 1.7 meter
desk because because i have the monitor
here my macbook pro logitech keyboard
here magic uh trackpad got harman kardon
speakers i've got this oc white ultima
uh mic arm here because this is how i do
my recording and my voiceover work got
the neumann tlm-107 mic here
i'm all set up right in this area this
side is relatively empty because this is
where i do a lot of my content where i
shoot a lot of my content where i'm
doing this kind of stuff right here and
also if i want to do some you know
photography of products or b-roll-on
products i will shoot it in this area
and behind me in the terrible display
case so that's sort of how i set up my
studio for the most part and that's why
i think this extra space
really helped me a lot using this desk
for the past couple weeks now unlike
other
desks out there where the controls to
move it up and down are an external
control panel this is built into the
tabletop it is very sleek it is very
awesome you have customizable buttons so
you can set different heights on this
you have an led panel so you can see the
height and measurements it's great it's
awesome i love it and it lights up as
well now we got to talk about the lights
in the back of it very reminiscent of
the original lights but now they're
controlled by nano leaf you have a
physical controller attached to the
lights also you can control by an app
and it's great flexible the same exact
design language except that physical
controller is nicer you can attach it to
your desk by a 3m tape that's included
and you don't worry about losing that
little
uh tiny controller that came with the
original magnus which i almost lost a
few times so you know this is nicer this
way i appreciate this now the cable bay
or tray
is a little different from the previous
version case in point that trap door
that was underneath on the original
magnus is no longer there secret lab
told us that a lot of people didn't use
that so they just took it out
also
it to me feels a little shallower now
secret lab says it's deeper but to me it
feels a little bit shallower if you're
having a problem
plugging in your larger power bricks
into this because you have a power strip
that's plugged into the back of it
you need to
flip or reverse that power strip inside
the cable tray that means if you have a
three prong system the two prongs are
facing the back and the front prong is
facing forward towards the desk then you
can plug these larger devices in if you
do it the other way you're not gonna get
anything in because of the the allotment
of room so keep that in mind a little
tip that i learned from secret lab
trying to set up this desk but speaking
of that bay
right there's also something else i want
to talk to you guys about and that's the
cable management on the side
and
it's a great idea to me it's a fantastic
idea but
there's something i want to show you
which makes it a little less than ideal
but i'll show you what i'm talking about
right now now on this side of the desk
you actually have a pc mount or tower
mount that you can hook up to this and
then you can actually run cables through
here and you'd be necessarily cable-free
to the you know outside world by theory
you should run the cables through here
into the cable tray
however here's the problem with this
while you can run cables here it stops
because for some reason there's just
this really small tiny opening here
which is not going to allow anything to
get through so if you have any sort of
power source anything like that you're
not going to get through that at all so
what you have to do is actually take the
cable out from there and then wrap it
around this way into the cable bay which
seems a little bit odd of a design now
case in point there are various
different sizes to let's say plugs or
whatever it may be
which could cause the secret lab to go
look maybe it's just easier to wrap it
around then they have no issues with
that at all but
if you want to make this as clutter free
and as sleek as possible
having this completely open on the
inside with a great a big opening here
to go in here into the cable tray would
have been ideal all right so
having said that let's talk about one of
the other benefits that i like about
this desk one plug goes from the bottom
of the desk the leg into the wall that
means all your power sources are plugged
into the desk itself through the power
strip that plugs into the side of the
desk there's a power outlet on the left
side the top left side
and then at the bottom left hand side
there's one cable that goes into the
wall and that's all you need to plug in
that means less wires are seen it means
it means a lot cleaner look in your room
in your studio
and to me i thought this was a genius
set up by secret lab i absolutely love
this desk my personal opinion is it's
one of the best standing desks in the
marketplace i love the sleek design i
like the accessories and i think a lot
of you out there are going to enjoy it
if there's any
uh negativity on this desk i would just
say it's the side cable management as i
mentioned earlier i wish it went all the
way into the bay without having to wrap
around but we can't have everything
right but for the most part they hit a
home run with this desk anyway those are
my thoughts on it let me know your
thoughts in the comment section below if
you like this review subscribe hit that
like button hit that notification bell
and we got a lot more great videos to
check out right here